I have the weirdest boner right now so  anyway I just have to eat 12 more boxes  of cereal and then I get a puffin you  know that's three minutes of my life  I just won't get back I make 90 dollars  an hour working from home same that's  when I knew I'd never really fall in  love ooh air hey did you see that  article I posted on your Facebook wall  TLDR wait what too long Dean read same  hey did you get my text about setting up  the cable box instructions not clear  Mike Jenkins cause the ceiling fan I  totally ship you guys OTP I haven't read  the books so I'm asking you please do  not spoil anything here regardless I'm  over at you irregardless isn't a word  yeah it is no it's not you're a [ __ ] oh  my god that Flay  same